joining me now for reaction is Tom
Holman the former acting director of ice
mr. Holman thank you so much for being
here and I really appreciate it I got to
tell you when I'm seeing what's going on
in Portland Oregon
yeah and beautiful Portland the history
of a lot of political activism that's
fine this is not your ordinary political
activism what's happening there that the
American people are not seeing because
the media will not adequately cover this
story what isn't happening when during a
time I saw you your clips earlier and
Chris Crane was right
the mayor has refused to take action on
those folks that have illegally
prevented us from doing our jobs by
starting our building down for over a
week how many child molesters Predators
traffickers weren't arrests of that week
how many criminal aliens aliens entered
this country illegally and committed yet
another crime war an arrest of that week
a lot of criminals are now walking
streets of Portland that would have been
arrested that week so the mayor turned
his back on the citizens of Portland for
his own political ambitions now Chris
Crane was talking about the antifa
infiltration or some would say takeover
of this protest are the run-of-the-mill
kind of millennial protesters with the
magic marker signs and the black mask
people kind of working hand in glove
there from what you're gathering yeah i
watch video of the Portland office show
down for several days and antifa was
there matter of fact the hunger and Tifa
flags up where the United States well
they took down the US flag they climbed
the building they took down the US flag
and they replaced it with an ante for
flag yes ma'am and the Patriot Patriots
at ice when they took the building back
first thing they did is raise the
American flag back up you know the only
thing I can think of is like that is
when Isis was rolling through parts of
Iraq and they were going into those
Christian villages and Mosul and so
forth they were they were knocking down
those churches taken off the crosses and
raising the ISIS flag I mean it's a it's
a form of domestic terror this pathetic
was going on in Portland that I don't
know who's worse than that mayor or the
mayor and alkalyn Oakland or
Philadelphia or New York I mean there's
there's a whole whole bunch of right now
who have never accepted this president
and and and they're gonna put their own
critic ambitions
I had the public safety of their
citizens and I want to remind the
Portland
I'm sure he's gonna hear about this
these ice employees are also taxpayers
and citizens of the city of Portland he
has a duty to protect them when they
call the police
Zephyr Teachout interesting name a
Democratic candidate for New York
Attorney General calls to abolish ice
and set it this way let's watch ice has
to be a ball and as Attorney General I
will continue to speak out against ice I
will prosecute ice for their criminal
acts we have stories of consistent abuse
within ice the idea that we could call
this law enforcement is a real offense
to the idea of law itself a real offense
I think she's mixing up her I think she
means offense but that's okay well I've
never seen that video but now I'm more
irritated and I wasn't walked in here
and what we're gonna cover that attorney
journal candidate candidate I hope
that's a far she gets look prosecute ice
agents ice officers and agents have
taken more than 5,000 criminal aliens
off the streets of New York that walked
out of their sanctuary jails ice has
done more for public safety in that
state than their own governor has ice
officers on northern border shut down
opioid trade and but they say Tom that
the reason they're upset is because
you're you're separating pant families
here you're focused on deporting these
families when you should be focused on
the illegal immigrants so they're
conflating Border Patrol of course HHS
the detainment centers and ice they're
putting them all in one big pot so they
say what you could do a better job if
you aren't focusing on these poor
children let me tell you something by
the hosts separating families I watched
the hearing yesterday I was quite
disturbed by some of the questions from
Democrats they kept wanting put the
blame on Borbon show HSS ice they had a
solid process for you know his family
because we've been separating families
for decades first of all this isn't new
it's that castration decades but if they
want they want to blame somebody
Congress needs to look in the mirror
because I've been up on the hill several
times along the head of CBP and and see
is talking about the loopholes the floor
is seldom agreement if they want these
folks to see a judge you claim asylum we
do to those our own way one way from
guarantee they see a judge's keeping a
family residential center
but they don't want to do that so they
refuse to fix a little poles so the
Attorney General did what he had to do
operationally to defend our border the
Attorney General did exactly what he
should have dollar insis the way to go
he was right we have a runaway judge
situation in this country who are acting
a super legislators judges San Diego and
a he ordered during the dinner during a
twenty five hundred unification stop
doing the DNA testing when we did the
DNA testing for the children under five
5 to 7 percent weren't the parents so if
you extrapolate that to twenty five
hundred people how many children do we
have to release the people that weren't
their parents because that judge decided
DNA was important Wow and the twenty
percent of the kids were not brought
across by their own parents twenty five
hundred children separated there's ten
thousand children in custody HHS that
were separated by their parents who
heard a criminal organization to put
their kid in the trunk of a car and
smuggle into United States who are these
parents is child abuse who these parents
who send their kids across the border
alone I'm sorry about what kind of watch
the clips early claim the administration
child abuse the child abuse is hiring a
criminal organization to put your kid in
a truck of car smuggling United States
Tom Holman hey great to see you
appreciate it over there at homeland
thanks I'm in the fight I